there's some professions that are super
complex in nature and take a long time
to become proficient deal making is one
no one like wakes up as like oh I took a
three-week course like it takes years to
become proficient and so I was thinking
about like how do I Define that that
there's enough diversity in the types of
interactions you have it takes a longer
time to become proficient at the thick a
mechanic or a surgeon or a lawyer it
takes a long time for them to accumulate
enough experiences where you can put
them in the wild and they're generally
proficient advertising is the same way
it takes a long time to like know what
it looks like for a direct consumer B2B
physical products software